một robot cao gần bằng người thật mang tên tế tám chăm
vừa sớt hiện trong đội hình tuần chà ở thâm quyến
với thân hình kiếm loại
lúc bốt này sớt hiện ngay cảnh lực lượng cảnh xác đặt nghiệm Trung Quốc
không bà mì thẳng tư
đây là robot hình người, soar and gene AI
công ty có chủ sở tại thâm quyến phát triển
robot cao khoảng 1 mổi bệm biệt bà mết
nặng khoảng 17,000 kí lâu gàm
được chăng bị cạm biến để cạm giận môi trường
giữ thân bằng và thực hiện các chuyển động phút tập
trong các video chỉ diễn trước đó
tế tám chăm từng về chuyển khi bởi giễn phó thuật
đã suy và di chuyển liên phạc
viên nhìn tiện chưa có thông viên cho thấy
robot này đã được viên chế chính thức
khoảng có thể đạm đẹp vụ cảnh xác đật lập
theo hẳng robot có hệ kết tòn thân
một phòng chuyển động người
vôm tay chân L-Cổ và bản tay liên phạc
tế tám chăm dùng thị giác lập thể
và lý đá để nhận biết bật cản
mối lần sạc tế tám chăm có thể khoảng 1.5 dơ
tế tám chăm dả mắt quốc tế
tại trên lắm để từ dùng CES 2.5 dơ
được NGN AI quảng 3
như một nền tảng robot tà dụ cho một dường tế